is this filmmaker jeremy corbell
no
can you say who the filmmaker is
um
why would i want to make him famous
that's what he's here for
i i have a nickname for him sure his
first name
rhymes with lion
because he's always lying but other than
that i'm not gonna yeah
okay well i have a question here about
ryan and i assume then it's the same
person the question is in a phone call
with ryan
you said this is what this person is
saying this is what steve campion is
saying
you said someone else was posting on
your facebook on your behalf so who is
this person that's the question
well that was just speculation about
people
going online and pretending to be me i
mean that's ridiculous how often that
happens
imposters that's all i'm not there
wasn't any some particular thing that
was being discussed
you know i had uh
some strange people over the years
people claiming to be
other than who they were
uh someone claiming to be the sheriff's
nephew
i talked to the sheriff about it and uh
didn't know who this could possibly be
claiming to know my kids and their
cousin
they don't know who it could possibly be
but he was making ridiculous claims
that he had the inside story people do
this all the time there's something big
in the news and i live in this area so
i'll make up some connection to this
to gain attention so he said when they
recovered my me from
the phone booth that my stomach was
covered with dirty needle marks
this is to suggest that the whole thing
was a drug hallucination
i actually had a
thorough medical examination a number of
examinations by a number of doctors
right after that
and blood and urine samples were
submitted to the maricopa county medical
examiner's drug screen
showed no trace of any drug
and of course the doctor examined uh my
naked body and there was no such marks
on me it was just a way to claim
uh some connection to something there's
a whole lot a bunch of other stuff that
he was claiming that we're just
uh about
where alan lived
you know
that he lived in concho which is a
quarter mile from snowflake
i mean this guy didn't even know the
geography of the area and he's a faking
faking laughter but you know what so
many people online spotted his lies they
were jumping before i even found out he
existed
but there's other connections other
people that um you know
some some a little bit more benign some
friendly you know there was a guy that i
was friends with
that uh said because he lived in heber
that when i made that phone call that
night from my family to rescue me
that i called him first and he wasn't
home so then i called my family
um
that's
an impossible set of priorities there
and
it's totally
falsified by the fact that when i called
it was that a collect call i had no
money on me
uh the operator listened in on the call
and reported to the sheriff
and the sheriff sent officers over there
that night
so
there was only one call
made and it was just
a kind of a
somebody trying to be important uh you
know i know this guy and
you know there were another a few other
claims that uh oh here's one uh i worked
with travis on the loud landing and uh
every morning when he'd come in
he'd take off his hard hat and line it
with fresh aluminum foil
basically saying travis is a tennis hat
guy and he's just totally i never worked
with
this guy on any log landing anywhere and
there were never any tin foil in my hard
hat
a few people here are saying
that i never doubted you travis that's
memo type
someone else is saying
well there's many plaudits in the
comments i can't get to them all well i
appreciate that and i i would like to
say thank you to those people